sono davvero felice di essere qui con
voi questa sera per me è un qualcosa di
abbastanza nuovo sono abituata a fa
esprimermi con le mie azioni con le mie
gare quindi diciamo che non sono proprio
a mio agio in questo momento però sono
davvero contenta che o questa occasione
di poter parlare con voi di poter
condividere con voi insomma parte della
mia storia parte della mia vita e
soprattutto un un processo che ho
costruito negli anni che ho imparato
negli anni voglio parlare con voi
di come tutti noi abbiamo bisogno di uno
spazio in cui crescere del perché
abbiamo bisogno di questo spazio e di
come creare questo spazio di crescita
io sono stata molto fortunata sono nata
e cresciuta in montagna quindi la natura
diciamo che fin da piccola è stata la
mia insegnante la mia insegnante di vita
sono cresciuto in un ambiente abbastanza
sicuro dove potevo permettermi di
commettere degli errori ma comunque
abbastanza pericoloso da capirne le
conseguenze se qualcosa fosse andato
storto
me piace dire ho avuto la libertà di
fallire
ho avuto la libertà di cadere e grazie
questi fallimenti a queste cadute che
fin da piccola sono riuscita a crescere
a evolver mi
vedete una foto di me e mio fratello non
ci piaceva tantissimo arrampicarsi sugli
alberi e le sbucciature le cadute ig
bolli vari
insomma sono stati i miei primi
insegnamenti
grazie a questo questo tipo di
insegnamenti che man mano si fanno
crescendo si impara anche a prendere le
decisioni migliori nella vita grazie a
questo processo
grazie al fatto di poter condividere
queste queste idee queste esperienze con
le persone possiamo anche migliorare la
società in cui viviamo
ed è questo quello che dovremmo aspirare
tutti quanti
ovviamente prendere le decisioni
migliori non sempre facile ci vuole
esperienza bisogna a volte buttarsi
a volte improvvisarsi però ne vale la
pena perché rimanere sempre fermi nello
stesso punto non porta mai niente
trovare delle nuove nuovi percorsi delle
nuove
spazi di crescita non è facile però
quando li si trova qualcosa che ti
cambia completamente la vita quando si
incontrano persone nuove persone che
hanno però la tua stessa tipo la tua
stessa mentalità il tuo stesso tipo di
divisione vedono le cose nel tuo stesso
modo però magari in altri aspetti in
altri ambiti in altre
culture
vergendo comunque conosciuto tante
persone quindi avuto la possibilità di
confrontarmi veramente con tantissime
persone dà la possibilità di crescere di
continuare a migliorarsi continuare ad
evolvere ed è questo la cosa
fondamentale che dobbiamo tutti capire
che tutti noi abbiamo bisogno di questo
spazio questo spazio in cui crescere e
questo spazio ovviamente
si evolve a sua volta in uno spazio dove
dobbiamo adattarci uno spazio dove
ovviamente magari all'inizio tu entri e
ed è tutto nuovo a e tante cose che vuoi
imparare ci sono tante persone che
possono davanti darti veramente tante
dritte tante prospettive diverse e tu
sei pieno di energie e voglia di
imparare da loro però arriverà quel
punto dove avrei ha preso tutto quello
che poteva apprendere a e ha preso tutto
quello che volevi da quello spazio e
allora dovrai capire che è il momento di
muoversi di adattarti di andare oltre e
qui devi trovare un nuovo spazio o lo
trovi o lo crei e lo crei non solo per
te ma per tutti gli altri
ora vorrei parlare un po delle mie
esperienze personali
vorrei legarmi al fatto appunto
dell'adattamento
quando dopo le olimpiadi di pyongyang mi
sono presa un anno di pausa quando sono
rientrata in squadra ho trovato un
ambiente diverso lo spazio di crescita
che avevo creato per me per tutti gli
altri era era diverso da quello che
avevo avevo costruito non era più un
ambiente dove potevamo tutti a
condividere essere noi stessi poter
crescere insieme erano ambiente più
chiuso solo provato a restarci ho
provato a cambiare le cose cerca di
ricostruire quello che avevo creato ma
alla fine della stagione avevo capito
purtroppo che non
non potevo fare nessun cambiamento e
quindi mi sono dovuta adattare e quindi
mi sono trasferita in ungheria e sono
andata alla ricerca di un nuovo spazio
dove poter crescere
questo spazio non è stato facile da
trovare
diciamo che ci sono voluti un po di un
po di mesi prima di trovarlo però una
volta trovato è stato veramente un molto
eccitante per me perché mi sono
ritrovata in una in un ambiente un nuovo
un nuovo spazio in un nuovo ambiente con
persone di diversa cultura diversa
metodi di allenamento diverse che
veramente mi hanno di nuovo aperto un
mondo
ed è grazie insomma a questo questo
nuovo spazio alle persone che erano
intorno a me e al processo che abbiamo
costruito insieme per attivare il nostro
spazio di crescita che sono riuscito a
raggiungere poi mi obiettivi
la prima cosa che bisogna fare è trovare
insomma questo nuovo spazio quando
magari si raggiunge un blocco trovare un
nuovo spazio o crearne uno nuovo non è
semplice però bisogna partire da una da
una forte passione e dalla voglia di
migliorare si sia questa cosa il primo
passo è fatto
una cosa che funziona per me che credo
che possa funzionare anche per tutti voi
e trovare il vostro perché perché lo
faccio perché voglio continuare a
pattinare perché voglio continuare a
fare fatica perché sono ancora qui
una volta che ho trovato il mio perché
ho tutta la forza che necessaria per
poter andare avanti per poter
raggiungere il mio obiettivo per
raggiungere il mio traguardo e
attraversarlo
una volta trovato questo perché la
motivazione bisogna lavorare sulle aree
di miglioramento
prima di tutto dobbiamo concentrarci sui
nostri punti di forza
una volta individuati questi punti di
forza si passa alle aree dove possiamo
migliorare maggiormente
per esempio quando sono entrate in
squadra per la prima volta io 15 anni e
pensavo di essere già già bravina però
purtroppo i risultati all'inizio non
arrivavano e
ci ho messo un po ci ho messo un po di
tempo per capire dove potevo migliorare
cosa potevo fare per migliorare sapevo
che sappiamo una delle mie
caratteristiche che mi caratterizza
ancora tutt'oggi e che sa leggere bene
le gare però quello non era abbastanza
dovevo migliorare e guardando le mie
avversarie con gli anni ho imparato che
loro erano molto più in forma di me la
loro tecnica era molto più efficace e
più efficiente e quindi ho capito che
era quello che dovevo concentrarmi
dovevo lavorare su questi questi aspetti
è quindi conseguenza ho imparato ho
capito che non potevo più rimanere nello
stesso posto dovevo cambiare tipo di
prospettiva
dovevo cambiare in modo di pensare non
potevo più rimanere ferma nello stesso
posto nello stesso punto fa le stesse
domande alle stesse persone dovevo
cambiare
e quindi qui ho iniziato a pormi delle
domande cosa potevo fare per cambiare
cosa potevo fare per migliorare e qui
diventa c'è la parte più più difficile
il passaggio che ho rispondo che ho
riscontrato più difficoltà
il fatto di poi porre queste domande ad
altre persone purtroppo ci sono persone
che vi hanno visto questo mio questa mia
volontà di migliorare questa mia voglia
di ricerca
di qualcosa di nuovo di innovativo come
un
non lo so ho una voglia di ribellione un
voler fare creare problemi quando invece
in realtà volevo solo migliorare e
migliorare il sistema in cui ero la
situazione in cui ero volevo che tutti
migliorassero insieme a me che potessimo
crescere insieme
però ho avuto direi coraggio e la forza
di continuare o persistito continuato a
fare domande finché poi ho trovato le
persone giuste
ho trovato delle persone che come me
anzi prima di me hanno passato quello
che ho passato io quello che stavo
passando persone che si erano già poste
queste domande che avevano già raggiunto
i loro obiettivi
e grazie a loro grazie alla loro
esperienza sono riuscita poi ad avere
intorno a me delle persone che mi hanno
aiutata
avere delle persone della specola stessa
mentalità ti può aiutare moltissimo
perché anche se il suono fanno parte
diciamo di un altro di un altro ambiente
la loro professione un'altra cosa che
non riguarda assolutamente quello che
stai facendo tu però hanno la sua stessa
mentalità la tua stessa voglia di
migliorare la tua stessa voglia di
crescere insieme si possono raggiungere
veramente delle cose grandiose
quando quando è stato
sono già successe talmente tante cose
nel
2016 circa ho capito che per poter
vincere l'odio primo oro nel
nelle olimpiadi successive nel 2018
dovevo cambiare qualcosa io ero convinta
che a soci nel 2014 avrei vinto l'oro
olimpico e avrei smesso e invece poi ho
continuato ben oltre
perché in quel momento nel 2016 ho
trovato una persona che veramente mi ha
cambiato completamente
la vita a mi ha sconvolto tutto il mio
programma di allenamento ha capito
quello che volevo fare quello che volevo
raggiungere e mi ha aiutato a farlo
ho cominciato a lavorare con anthony il
mio allenatore
allora nel 2016 ha cominciato a
programmare una una programmazione di
allenamento completamente diversa mi ha
detto quell'estate prima delle olimpiadi
del 2018 mi ha detto arriverai olimpiadi
che avrai una marcia in più avrai una
marcia clan ma non avrei mai avuto prima
e
in effetti sono arrivata poi è più al
shanghai ho vinto il mio primo l'oro
olimpico
doppio piano chung
ovviamente siamo rimasti concentrati
sulla sulla parte fisica sulla parte
mentale però abbiamo anche cominciato a
lavorare sulle parti più tecniche sui
nostri attrezzi sui miei attrezzi sui
pattini e sulle lame soprattutto le lame
sono degli attrezzi che sono anni che
nessuno fa niente sono le stesse da anni
nessuno cambia niente e noi abbiamo
detto ma perché non proviamo qualcosa di
nuovo perché non proviamo a tre provare
ad utilizzare dei materiali diversi e
quindi abbiamo iniziato questo nuovo
viaggio questo siamo andati alla ricerca
di questo nuovo spazio in cui poter
crescere questa nostra idea e abbiamo
trovato questo produttore di lame e
droghe che è un olandese e lui quando vi
abbiamo parlato dalla nostra idea e si è
visto subito che nei suoi occhi si è
acceso qualcosa c'era questa questa luce
che brillava nei suoi occhi lui
finalmente aveva trovato qualcuno che
come che lo avesse un po come dire
sfidato nel trovare qualcosa di nuovo di
innovativo e dal iniziato questo questo
bellissimo viaggio questo bellissimo
percorso con lui e
c'è stato questo
mega brainstorming tra trame anthony
edwards i suoi collaboratori ho provato
non so quante lama e durante questi due
anni
però alla fine siamo arrivati dove a
pechino io vivo le mie lame
personalizzate e nessun altro aveva
questo tipo di lame
al mondo esistono solo tre lame e le ho
io e questo è stato qualcosa veramente
unico incredibile riuscire a raggiungere
questo obiettivo insieme
è stato qualcosa di veramente fantastico
perché siamo riusciti a
collaborare far fluire le nostre
idee e la nostra idea si è poi evoluta
l'abbiamo fatta evolvere
c'è voluto del tempo ma alla fine è
arrivato il risultato è questa la cosa
più importante
ora
quello che che vorrei insomma che
vorrei riuscire a trasmettere a voi è
proprio questo il fatto di uscire dalla
vostra comfort zone di fallire perché va
bene fallire perché i fallimenti le
cadute sono il modo più facile in modo
più semplice per imparare dai nostri
errori
vorrei che insomma trovate questo modo
il vostro modo per costruire uno spazio
dove potete crescere dove potrete
confrontarvi con altre persone dove
potete imparare e devolver v vi chiedo
questo perché so che funziona perché ha
funzionato per me e so che può
funzionare per voi e se volete la prova
grazie